welcome to this video plate a national
master
yuck icon okay and what does this
there's something in there I know don't
know don't know the name so let's see
what we get
what put a play just for for the
righteous sake how long maybe the Kings
in yin or the four pawn is a check and I
usually if you get that you know that
the white player serious about it
getting after you
yeah well this is the side gotten
earlier and I still don't know what to
do against it just 94 mmm I really have
forgotten at least this is quick play
hints at this being a possible line
whatever the quality is of the line now
okay can I go if five years somehow now
I can take this doesn't look too great
hmm yeah I don't know what to do I don't
really know what's going on in this
slide yeah that's so that's of course a
problem if you vary the openings a lot
like I do here for all the videos if
someone plays a very principled and
somewhat rare line like this oftentimes
I really have to make it up make it up
as I go along
I really don't don't know what's what's
right what about this I can take a
jagged edge five shouldn't this be a
decent a decent way to defend this I'll
take it in the night aged five maybe
even less of this would be five know
this seems seems right at least there I
get the Queen's off
okay I expect him to go f5 now other if
he doesn't I mean he cannot allow me to
capture this is just just very fine yeah
he went for that as expected
yeah my night obviously is very far off
from the important squares in this
position b5 mostly the n95 could easily
be the next month
you cannot go f6 that's that's good at
least we can go fishin g5 now well this
is also a pro an issue but yeah every
night f4 hmm but should be 5-4 so maybe
okay I'd be forget 6 ok well it doesn't
matter I didn't play it of course I
don't go back I mean I rather sacrifice
españa for activity now I have a very
good Bishop on g7 should I put it on e5
yeah I guess so makes lots of sense and
now what's my play here should I go for
if he pushes f6 f king f7 if he takes
hmm it doesn't scare me that much okay
try to prepare b5 Bishop c6 was another
good move actually just to be ready to
capture the knight coming to d5 so b5 or
is there something terrible happening to
me I don't see it at the moment ok ok so
we wanted to I'd wants to take with the
bishop yeah that that makes lots of
sense so before
maybe just here f6 doesn't scare me
really I go to f7 it's okay okay
she wants to simply take now maybe yeah
I simply I simply try to have faith in
my bishop an even in case of an endgame
so bishops is six now right I might play
97 hmm okay oh wait f6 I cannot go to f7
then which I can I can actually do that
there is not there is no super terrible
discovered check check maybe there is
might be six seven could be could be a
bit tricky check no this is wrong okay
so if he takes here I can maybe get some
play against you form he is going to
play f7
yeah okay I probably should avoid it
and now cook age three I have age five
at least to defend it for the moment
yeah well I'm obviously much worse but
maybe maybe I can still hold I would on
him and try to defend oh is giving me
3/5 this well 96 of course and rupees 7
time was certainly certainly in the mix
but I can take effects as well
not sure how terrible that really is 96
this losing I'm not sure but I need to I
need to to do this all night net no 96
that's that's that's bad
bull okay come on this is this is a
really reasonable yeah well after the
pawn sec I'm perfectly all right but I
need to continue me to play better
simply this is this is okay for black
I'm pretty sure that I have enough
compensation but I probably played it
simply plated badly around here I mean I
don't know or maybe just maybe Jesus g5
businesses - too much hmm
I don't know really just here to always
take it I mean this is just a very
strong piece I I think that it should be
quite okay hmm
I mean something like that besides the
fact that b2 hangs I mean this is just
not doing anything for a while and he's
got this very bad bishop I don't know it
could be it could be enough
yeah B Bishop g5 was what I feared and
this is much stronger and I really don't
know what to do now I cannot go here we
call them f6 something like that one is
also not too too thrilling which means
that Bishop d7 was a pretty bad move I
probably need to play Knight f4 here
already yeah okay I'm I'm sort of
improvising here
I mean computer once take yeah and it's
it's in fact very obvious yeah my
mistake was I thought about this briefly
and I thought that after Bishop here
knowledge 5 does not make much sense
because of this that's true but I can
actually go here and this is immediately
good for black and quite obviously so I
have this big check coming if he does
that now check
yeah or can i can take yeah even you
know this is check check check check
this does not lead to anything that wide
ones now and then Bishop g5 isn't the
move then why this just was just worse
here you know the computer gives this is
the best line check which is just
terrible for white yeah this is what I
needed to do but okay I I really don't
know this the screen edge fall looked
looked fishy to me I thought you might
hear rocky should take actually but it's
it's hard to do if you don't really know
the details alright thanks for watching